[Musique]
bonsoir les petits amis je crois que
mirabel et p'tit louis attendent gros
ours et qu'ils sont très pressés de le
voir ce soir je dois leur montrer
l'album de photos de notre voyage mais
ne restent pas plus de cinq minutes
tu as compris gros ours
nous nous étions à temps pour faire les
fous tout votre voyage je vais voulait
montrer venez on va s'asseoir là bas il
y en a beaucoup elles sont belles venez
venez vite elle encore oui oui vous
allez voler oui oui vous allez voir une
sont prêts mais la voilà voilà les
enfants maintenant nous partons en
voyage avec unissent à vous pas trop les
dessins se voit qu'ils aient fait
lorsque nous sommes partis au mois de
décembre il faisait très froid
le ciel était tout gris et nous n'avons
rencontré qu'un pauvre petit oiseau
perdu qui cherchait son nid car il avait
très faim nous sommes arrivés dans un
pays plein de jolies fleurs qui sentait
très bon et le petit oiseau qui était
venu avec nous sur notre nuage est
descendu pour picorer les fleurs et se
faire un beau petit nid avec les brins
d'herbe qui l'avait ramassée
mais gros jour c'est moi nous avons
continué notre long voyage
nous avons alors survolé une mer immense
qui étaient tout bleus mais n'avons pas
vu de poisson ouais non ça n'avait rien
mais non mais non il n'y avait pas de
poisson ils s'étaient tous caché au fond
de l'eau bon d'accord il y avait un
poisson nous sommes arrivés au bout de
la mer et nous avons survolé un très
beau pays où il y avait des arbres qui
avaient l'air de danse et tout à coup au
coin d'une rivière
on a vu un énorme crocodile qui avaient
des dents terrible et gros ours a eu
très peur heureusement que plus loin il
y avait un lyon très gentil qui est même
venu nous donner la patte et qui nous a
présenté à toute sa petite famille
car il avait deux beaux petits enfants
et aussi beaucoup beaucoup d'amis des
zèbres très amusant et une grosse maman
rhinocéros qui se promenait avec son
bébé est seul dans un coin le seigneur
king comme grosos avait très peur nous
avons dit au revoir aux jolis petits
chaos là et avons continué notre voyage
et nous sommes réveillés un jour dans un
pays où il n'y avait que de la glace et
de curieuses aux gens habillés de noir
et blanc nous ont reçus très aimablement
c'était messieurs et mesdames les
pingouins et voilà que tout d'un coup
dans toute cette glace je ne savais pas
que gros ours avait un riche cousin qui
faisait le tour du monde en automobile
mais malgré tout ses nombreux amis qui
étaient très gentils avec nous et qui ne
savaient que faire pour nous faire
plaisir
petit louis et mirabel nous manquait
vraiment de trop et nous sommes revenus
aussi vite que possible et retrouver et
vous retrouvez vous tous aussi voilà qui
est bien partir en voyage vous allez
partir en voyage en allant vite au dodo
et en faisant de borel à jour au lit
merci c'est un très beau voyage
merci de mousse au revoir les enfants à
demain
[Musique]
à demain petits enfants embrasser vite
vos parents et en dormez vous bien
sagement au revoir petit louis au revoir
mirabel bonne nuit
bonne nuit à deux mains
[Musique]